Mount Abu is a town in Rajasthan the
largest state in India Mart Arbor itself
is considered a holy mountain unto which
the Hindu divinities descended to earth
our restaurant is situated on a lightly
thoroughfare
it's speciality is a typical regional
dish Darbar tea
every day for ten years Niraj single has
prayed for his restaurant to succeed but
that alone is not enough God have you
[ __ ] papa
we're here in the middle of town and
there's a lot of competition so you have
to offer especially high quality to
stand out and we've done that quite well
his head Baker makes up to 450 parties
per day
Darmody is quite a hearty dish so many
people come here on the way to work
because it keeps you going for a long
time what I just done me a victim
while Abbate bread rolls spiced with
cumin are getting crispy in the oven the
chef prepares the dark onions garlic
garam masala and fresh herbs are fried
then the lentils are added mixed with
sharply spiced ghee the snack is ready
to serve
adil has a lot of regular customers
at a price the equivalent of one euro
sixty per serving dal baati is also
affordable for families that is very
spicy depending meets the door
the usual
and those who tried it once always come
back to Abu at the foot of the holy
mountain